[Musique]
m
vous
moi
[Musique]
ça y est les déjeuners servis en
français bien pressé ce matin du moins à
francine est impliqué que choisit va te
laver les dents ou mais au fond ce n'est
pas ça ça pique la langue ils ont le
tricheur 3 montgaillard tu as quand même
te laver les dents mais maman soit vu
que la france n'était pas servi de
savoir ça dans fm
oh mon dieu qu'est la laine ce n'était
pas laver les dents ce matin mais si
maman mais d'ambri mais nous on ne
comprend plus rien
une brosse à dents et dentifrice baby et
oui c'est grâce à vous tous et vous
[Musique]
prend vos madame voir votre vaisselle
étincelles ça donne une idée la douane
forme pauvres créé deux chiens oh là là
quelle catastrophe
[Musique]
alphand ne veut pas rentrer comme sa
maman va se passer l'un de ces savants
[Musique]
mais qu'est ce que vont faire des petits
tout m
mais oui les étoiles france tout
simplement
[Musique]
[Applaudissements]
merci ou et watteau et le lendemain
matin c'est bien en france
tu as bien compris
[Musique]
tu viens jouer avec nous la mousse
chouette les petits bateaux à tout se
transforme en gouttes de pluie tandis
que d'autres lancent des savons des
gants les tubes de dentifrice et
finalement c'est sympa de se laver
[Musique]
brown qui les bulls half ans
merci voiture à tous au revoir
[Musique]